.
Was macht uns zur Frau
oder zum Mann?
Der Körper?
Oder das eigene Empfinden?
* Melancholischer Popsong
"Getting Older" von Billie Eilish *
Die meisten Menschen
wissen schon früh,
ob sie
ein Mädchen oder ein Junge sind.
Von aussen ist dagegen
nicht unbedingt erkennbar,
welches Geschlecht
eine Person empfindet.
Denn nicht bei allen Menschen
stimmt das äusserliche Geschlecht
mit dem gefühlten Geschlecht überein.
Davon handelt diese Geschichte.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wenn ich mich selbst betrachte,
verstehe ich,
wieso sie mich seltsam finden.
Soraya ist 13 und eines der
jüngsten Transmädchen der Schweiz.
Als Junge fühlte ich mich seltsam,
irgendwie eklig.
So wurde aus Josué, dem Jungen,
ein Mädchen namens Soraya.
Das Coming-out als Teenager
schafft in der Schule Probleme.
Die machen einen auf cool.
Soraya ist bereit, alles auf sich
zu nehmen, um zur Frau zu werden.
Das ist lustig.
Langsam sollte es
etwas schneller gehen,
weil ich diese Tabletten
schon seit eineinhalb Jahren nehme.
Sechs Jahre begleiten wir Soraya
und ihre Familie auf ihrem Weg.
Hallo zusammen,
schön, seid ihr da, kommt rein.
Soraya und Eliana haben die Einladung
einer Zürcher
Sekundarschule angenommen.
Soraya will
von ihren Erfahrungen erzählen,
um Schülerinnen und Schüler
für das Thema Transidentität
bei Jugendlichen zu sensibilisieren.
Sie selber hat in der Schule
immer wieder Ausgrenzung erlebt.
Welche Garderobe
benutzt du z.B. beim Sport?
Die Frauengarderobe -
und das Mädchen-WC.
Wie machst du das im Schwimmbad,
oder wenn du ans Meer gehst?
Ich trage dann immer Shorts.
Oben trägt sie einen Bikini,
dann schwimmt sie los.
Aber ich bin voll die Wasserratte.
Anfangs befürchtete sie,
dass man einen Abdruck sieht.
Aber bei ihr wurde
die Pubertät mit zwölf blockiert.
Deshalb gibt es
nicht so viel zu verstecken,
wie wenn man
die Pubertät mit 16 blockiert.
Fürchtest du dich vor der Operation,
oder freust du dich?
Die Schmerzen machen mir Angst,
aber ich freue mich auch
mega auf das Ergebnis.
Ich werde nach der Operation
endlich das Teil los sein,
das schuld ist, an all dem, was ich
in meinem Leben nicht haben kann.
Darauf freue ich mich, aber ich habe
auch Angst vor den Schmerzen.
Nachher kannst du also
keine Kinder mehr bekommen?
Nein.
- Keine eigenen.
Schönes Wochenende.
Tschau.
- Tschüss.
Tschüss
- Tschau.
Ich hatte sozusagen die Wahl,
entweder in die männliche Pubertät
kommen zu wollen
und dann
noch Kinder bekommen zu können.
Also dann könnte ich
meine Samen einer Frau spenden,
die dann mein Kind bekommen kann.
Aber dazu sagte ich:
"Nein, das mache ich nicht"
und begann, Hormonblocker zu nehmen.
Soraya und ihr Vater
sind auf dem Weg ins Tessin.
Sie wollen ein paar Tage
gemeinsam verbringen.
* Rockmusik *
Mittlerweile hat Titus akzeptiert,
dass aus dem früheren Sohn
eine Tochter wurde.
Er hat lange dafür gebraucht,
einiges gar zu verhindern versucht.
Auch wenn er
nicht Sorayas leiblicher Vater ist,
sind sich die beiden sehr nah.
Ja, es kann auch sein,
dass es einmal Streit gibt,
wenn man auf so engem Raum ist.
Sie ist auch schon davongelaufen.
Irgendwo in Italien am Meer ...
... plötzlich war sie weg,
und ich hatte keine Ahnung.
Aber irgendwann
kam sie wieder zurück.
Soraya eckt auch in der Schule
und bei Freunden oft an.
Sie ist unzufrieden mit ihrem Körper.
Das Frauwerden geht ihr zu langsam.
* Fröhliche elektronische Musik *
Soraya, löse mich ab!
Machst du schon schlapp?
2, 3 Min.,
dann wechseln wir uns wieder ab.
Reicht das jetzt nicht?
- Nein.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
- Es muss prallvoll sein.
Titus macht sich Sorgen, weil Soraya
kein Interesse für einen Beruf zeigt.
In zwei Monaten wird sie
die 3. Sekundarschule beenden -
ohne einen Plan, wie's weitergeht.
Wir haben schon so viele Sachen
in Betracht gezogen,
aber noch nichts hat funktioniert.
Weil sie sich für nichts inte-
ressierte, dachte ich auch schon:
Vielleicht muss der Beruf erst
erfunden werden, der zu ihr passt.
Es kommt vor,
dass ich mir Sorgen mache.
Oh mein Gott,
das sieht aus wie ein Wasserfall.
Paps, was ist das?
- Ein Wasserfall.
Echt jetzt?
- Ja.- Oh, geil.
2 m geht es hinunter.
- Ha, ha, ha.
Oh!
Oha! Oops!
Oh Papa,
hier hat es Felsen, Achtung!
* Sie schreit und lacht. *
Jetzt bin ich voll nass.
Los Paps, hilf doch mal, wir steuern
direkt auf diesen Felsen zu.
Du laberst pausenlos irgendwas.
Papa,
wir hätten links fahren sollen.
Achtung Papa,
jetzt hilf doch auch mal mit!
Soraya!
Ich schaue.
- Wir knallen gegen den Felsen.
Ach, jetzt haben wir
den spannenden Teil verpasst.
Soraya, bitte tu mir den Gefallen
und halt endlich deinen Mund.
Aber wegen dir haben wir
den spannenden Teil verpasst.
Hör auf!
Denkst du wirklich, ich sei schuld?
Ja, du tust nichts.
Halt jetzt einfach deinen Mund,
es nervt, es nervt mich echt!
Und mich nervt,
dass du nie was tust.
Sie motzt permanent.
- Gar nicht wahr!
Und ich bin schuld an allem.
- Du musst dich bewegen!
Ja, es wird jeweils
schnell wieder gut.
Es kracht manchmal etwas ...
Du hast mir noch nie eine geknallt.
- Nein, es kracht ...
... zwischen uns.
- Aha.- Die Luft vibriert.
Also dieses Sprichwort habe ich
noch nie gehört.- Noch nie?
Kurze Zeit später
ist der Konflikt vergessen.
Soraya weiss, was sie an Titus hat.
Brr, es wurde kalt.
Mit ihm kann man
tolle Abenteuer erleben.
Aber eigentlich
ist er ein feinfühliger Mensch.
Und er ist immer für mich da.
Lass uns weiterfahren.
- Ja.
Brr, es ist so kalt.
Die obligatorische Schulzeit endet,
Soraya startet ins 10. Schuljahr.
Morgen besuche ich meine
neue Schule, mein erster Schultag.
Und ich habe Angst,
habe v.a. Angst,
dass dort blöde Leute sein könnten.
Und irgendwie habe ich
auch Angst vor mir selber,
dass ich etwas vergessen könnte,
oder dumme Sachen ...
... sage.
Hoffentlich wird es
in dieser Klasse besser laufen
als in den beiden vorherigen.
Ja, tschüss.
Sorayas Transidentität
führte in der Vergangenheit
immer wieder zu Problemen mit Jungs.
In der neuen Klasse will sie sich
deshalb nicht als trans outen.
Wir filmen sie daher
auch nicht in der Schule.
Zu meiner neuen Klasse
wollte ich nur kurz sagen,
dass es unter den Jungs einen gibt,
dessen Lächeln
mich einfach schmelzen lässt.
Wenn er mich anschaut ...
Es ist einfach ein Traum.
Der Traum droht,
wenige Tage später zu platzen.
Heute aber sah ich einen Typen,
der mich direkt erkannt hat.
Er sagte: "Du bist mit mir zusammen
in den Kindergarten gegangen."
Und ich so: Nein!
Nachher ging ich zur Schulleitung,
die wissen das ja.
Und sie sagten: "Ja, dann müssen wir
jetzt ein Outing machen."
Jetzt muss ich mich wieder einmal
outen, das kackt mich übelst an.
Das Gefühl
war einfach zu schön und zu toll,
mich als normales Mädchen zu fühlen
anstelle von Transgender.
Jetzt muss ich wieder
zu diesem Transgender werden.
Das Coming-out an der neuen Schule
bleibt ihr dann aber doch erspart.
Soraya und die Schulleitung
bitten den Jungen,
das Geheimnis für sich zu behalten,
was dieser auch tut.
Um das Versteckspiel zu beenden,
will Soraya endlich
auch ihre Ausweise ändern lassen.
Bist du jetzt etwas nervös -
oder gar nicht?
Nein.
- Gar nicht? Ich schon.
Hast du die ID dabei?
- Ja, wieso?
Die Identitätskarte
lautet noch auf: Josué, männlich -
daraus soll endlich:
Soraya, weiblich, werden.
So.
Es ist mir wichtig,
weil ich von der Gesellschaft
jetzt schon fast
als Frau akzeptiert wurde,
nun auch vom Staat
als Frau akzeptiert zu werden.
Was bringt es, einem Mädchen
einen Jungennamen zu geben?
Das macht doch keinen Sinn.
Die Familie muss
dem Gericht glaubhaft machen,
dass Soraya sich als Frau fühlt,
erst dann
werden die Papiere geändert.
Seit dem 1. Januar 2022
ist das anders:
Eine Geschlechtsänderung ist
einfach und unbürokratisch möglich.
Der Entscheid wird einige Wochen
oder länger auf sich warten lassen.
Überraschend hat sich aber auf einem
anderen Gebiet eine Chance eröffnet.
Soraya darf eine Schnupperlehre
als Dentalassistentin machen.
Horsholm-Sonde.
- Perfekt.
Ach, das vergiss ich immer.
- Paro-Sonde.
Paro-Sonde und Zahnarztpinzette.
- Genau.
Was benötigen wir hier noch,
damit wir bohren können?
Ah, das Ding,
welches man ins Öl taucht?
Die Assistina, genau,
die Winkelstücke.
Ein rotes und ein blaues.
Wohin kommt das rote?
Immer auf die rechte Seite.
Gut, lass uns jetzt
den Patienten holen.
Persönliche Kontakte der Mutter haben
ihr die Schnupperlehre ermöglicht.
Aufgrund der Noten hätte man Soraya
nicht eingeladen, sagt man ihr offen.
* Elektronische Klänge *
Jetzt brauchen wir den Sauger,
damit kannst du den Rest absaugen.
Soraya stellt sich
äusserst geschickt an.
Gehe ganz nahe ran.
Die Mitarbeitenden der Praxis
kennen Sorayas Geschichte,
sie haben keine Berührungsängste
mit ihrer Transidentität.
Mein erster Eindruck von dir
ist sehr positiv.
Für mich reicht
normalerweise ein "Gut".
Aber da muss ich wirklich sagen,
du verdienst ein "Sehr gut".
Ich hatte noch nie jemanden,
der so offen wie du
auf die Patienten zugeht,
sehr viel Interesse am Beruf zeigt,
und auch Fragen stellt.
Also, das ist wirklich top,
muss ich sagen.- Danke.
Ich bin wirklich sehr begeistert.
Weil ihr mir gleich
Vertrauen entgegengebracht habt,
habe ich mich sofort
sehr wohl gefühlt bei euch.
Ihr habt mich nie alleine gelassen
und dafür gesorgt,
dass ich immer Arbeit hatte.
Ihr habt mir alles erklärt
und mich herumgeführt.
Das fand ich sehr nett von euch,
dafür möchte ich mich bedanken.
Schön, das ist ebenfalls
nicht selbstverständlich.
Das finde ich total schön, wenn das
von einer 16-Jährigen kommt,
wenn das auch geschätzt wird.
Das ist wirklich extrem schön.
Das waren wirklich zwei tolle Tage.
- Ja, das finde ich auch.
Cool.
- Danke vielmals.
Gern geschehen, also,
dann gehen wir uns umziehen.
Soraya darf sich
für die Lehrstelle bewerben.
Endlich eine berufliche Perspektive!
Damit würde auch für die Eltern
eine Sorge wegfallen.
Titus und Eliana
sind seit vielen Jahren geschieden,
teilen sich aber das Sorgerecht
für Soraya, die bei der Mutter lebt.
Titus hat
einen Brief des Gerichts bekommen.
Er vermutet
einen wichtigen Entscheid.
Soraya.
Hier ist der Brief.
- Hier ist er.
Wenn es ein schlechtes Ergebnis ist,
verbrenne ich den Brief
über diesen Kerzen.- Mhm.
Lies vor.
- Ja, ich bin ja dran.
Urteil vom 6. Dezember 2019.
Es wird erkannt ...
Das Gesuch wird gutgeheissen
und es wird festgestellt,
dass der Gesuchsteller
nun weiblichen Geschlechts ist.
Zweitens: Dem Gesuchsteller
wird die Vornamensänderung
von Josué Jonas in Soraya bewilligt.
Yay! Das ist alles, den Rest
brauchst du nicht vorzulesen,
das war der schönste Teil.
Können wir nun anstossen und feiern?
Ich gratuliere dir.
Hat ja bloss ein Jahr gedauert.
- Aber jetzt ist es so weit.
Eine Stunde, zwei Stunden.
Boah!
Versuch mal zu drehen,
auf die andere Seite.
Oops!
Papi, du wusstest genau,
dass dies passieren wird.
Nun ist es amtlich:
Soraya ist eine Frau -
fast vier Jahre
nach ihrem Coming-out.
Heute ist der 13. Februar,
oh Gott, morgen ist Valentinstag.
Irgendwie habe ich jetzt
einen Freund.
Also ja, ein Freund, eigentlich.
Und ja irgendwie ...
... ist mein Schulleben
jetzt gerade perfekt.
Und ja, er weiss es,
ich habe es ihm erzählt.
Er war einmal bei mir,
und wir haben zwei perfekte Tage
miteinander verbracht.
Also, er schlief bei mir.
Aber es ist nichts Krasses passiert.
Wie auch?
Ich glaube, das klingt jetzt voll
komisch, aber mein erstes Mal
wird wohl viel krasser -
das ist jetzt nicht böse gemeint -
aber es wird viel krasser sein
als bei "normalen" Mädchen,
weil ich voll
so hart dafür kämpfen muss.
Ihr hingegen könnt es tun,
wenn ihr dazu bereit seid,
wenn ihr den Richtigen gefunden
habt, oder so, keine Ahnung.
Ich will die Operation
jetzt einfach machen lassen.
In der Schweiz gibt es drei Kliniken,
welche geschlechtsanpassende
Operationen vornehmen.
Soraya ist eben erst 17 geworden -
aussergewöhnlich jung, um sich
den Penis entfernen zu lassen
und an seiner Stelle
Vulva und Vagina zu bekommen.
Ich schätze, Sie haben
sich schon vorinformiert.
Bei der Operation
werden die Hoden entfernt
und gleichzeitig
wird die Harnröhre neu eingenäht.
Weil man sie natürlich kürzen
und dort hinbringen muss,
wo sie biologisch hingehört.
Ich kann Ihnen das
grob schematisch aufzeigen.
Bei der Konstruktion der Neo-Vagina
wird die Klitoris
aus Teilen der Eichel gemacht,
die kleinen Schamlippen
aus Teilen der Vorhaut.
Hier ist der Eingang zur Vagina.
Nerven und Gefässe, die Klitoris
bzw. Eichelanteile versorgen,
bleiben erhalten und
daraus wird die Klitoris gemacht.
Wie steht es mit Empfindsamkeit
und Orgasmusfähigkeit?
Was für Erfahrungen
habt ihr da gemacht?
Die Orgasmusfähigkeit liegt bei
über 95 % bei unseren Patientinnen,
die Sensibilität, d.h., dass man an
der Klitoris etwas spürt, bei 98 %.
Praktisch fast alle unsere
Patientinnen spüren etwas.
Es gibt aber ein Problem.
Weil das Peniswachstum früh
mit Spritzen blockiert wurde,
ist bei Soraya wenig Haut vorhanden,
um die Vagina zu bilden.
Entweder wird diese nur kurz,
oder der Arzt verwendet
zusätzlich ein Stück Darm.
Der Darm produziert Schleim
und der kann unangenehm riechen.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass wir das
machen müssen, das will ich nicht,
aber du musst entscheiden.
- Das ist egal.
Du sagtest doch auch,
du wolltest kein ...
Aber wenn es nur ein Teil ist,
muss man es eben machen .
Aber es riecht trotzdem, Soraya.
Du wirst immer Binden
und Slipeinlagen tragen müssen.
Und ... nein.
Die Wartezeit für diese Operation
beträgt rund zehn Monate.
Wir haben eine grosse Nachfrage
und machen sehr viele
dieser Operationen.
Vergangenes Jahr machten wir
27 Geschlechtsangleichungen,
und im Jahr davor waren es 21 -
Tendenz steigend.
Es ist doof,
dass ich noch so lange warten muss.
V.a., weil ich mich
innerlich darauf gefreut habe,
dass es in den nächsten fünf Monaten
passieren würde,
Und jetzt heisst es, in den
nächsten zehn bis zwölf Monaten.
Aber ja ...
Wir nehmen uns
eine Woche Zeit zum Überlegen.
Ich werde trotzdem
noch etwas recherchieren.
Es gibt noch ein Problem,
neben der Wartezeit.
Ich muss diese Woche
eine schwierige Entscheidung treffen
und zwar wegen meiner Operation.
Soll ich das mit dem Darm machen?
Oder ....
Oder nur 10 cm tief?
Also, ich spreche vom Schacht,
übrigens.
Und ...
Ich kann mich nicht entscheiden.
Die Operation wird Sorayas Leben
für immer verändern.
Was, wenn sie mit dem Ergebnis
nicht zufrieden sein wird?
Auch zwei Wochen
nach dem Termin im Spital
hat sich Soraya noch nicht
für eine Methode entscheiden können.
Die Mutter unterstützt sie, wo sie
kann, aber es geht um Sorayas Körper.
Wenn ich mich für eine der
beiden Methoden entscheiden würde,
dann hätte ich in zehn, elf
Monaten die Operation hinter mir.
Aber ich will nicht die schnellste
Lösung, sondern was am besten ist.
Wir sind jetzt daran,
neue Ärzte in Basel anzuschauen ...
... und in München.
Wir wollen herausfinden,
wie diese das machen.
Und ich habe keine Zweifel:
"Oh, vielleicht
sollte ich es doch nicht tun."
oder "Vielleicht sollte ich mir
noch etwas Zeit lassen."
Ich will mir nur mehr Zeit lassen
für diese krasse Entscheidung,
welche der beiden Optionen
die richtige ist.
Aber die Entscheidung, Ja oder Nein,
habe ich schon längst gefällt.
In München gibt es Ärzte,
die anders als in Zürich vorgehen.
Bei Soraya könnte
eine ausreichend tiefe Vagina
auch ohne Darmanteil
geschaffen werden.
Wir wollen es möglichst
originalgetreu schaffen
und möchten auch eine Scheidenhöhle,
die bei Erregung feucht wird.
Der gefährlichste Teil
an der Operation
ist immer noch die Schaffung
der neuen Scheidenhöhle.
Die neue Scheide wird geschaffen
zwischen dem Enddarm,
der Blase und der Prostata.
In diesem schmalen Raum
wird eine Höhle geschaffen.
Kann es zwischen hinterem
und vorderem Loch nicht reissen?
Ganz genau, da muss man aufpassen,
weil ein gewisses Risiko
für Verletzungen des Darmes besteht.
Es ist gut, das schon zwei-,
dreimal gemacht zu haben,
um auf der sicheren Seite zu sein.
Haben Sie
diese Woche schon operiert?
Ja, und heute auch noch eine, genau.
Das wird dann die dritte Genital-
angleichung in dieser Woche.
Damit die neu geschaffene Vagina
offen bleibt,
muss Soraya einen Stab einführen -
mehrmals täglich und über Monate.
Das nennt man Bougieren.
Ist das genau diese Grösse?
Ja, aber es gibt unterschiedliche
Grössen, grösser oder kleiner.
Am Anfang wird sie mit diesem
beginnen?- Auf jeden Fall.
Und dann immer grösser,
bis es nicht mehr geht?- Genau.
Das tun andere auch.
Flapsig ausgedrückt: Finden Sie
so was erst mal in freier Wildbahn!
Das werden die tollsten
Hausaufgaben, die ich je hatte.
Meine Kolleginnen
werden bestimmt neidisch sein.
Wenn Fragen sind,
bitte jederzeit melden.
Gut, danke vielmals.
- Vielen Dank.
Bei der Methode dieses Arztes wird
für die Schaffung der Neo-Vagina
mehr von Sorayas
vorhandener Haut verwendet,
als dies in Zürich der Fall wäre.
Soraya fällt ein Stein vom Herzen.
Ich fand das Gespräch mega gut.
Er ist mir sehr sympathisch,
er ist richtig selbstbewusst.
Er ist sehr selbstbewusst.
Er versteht sein Handwerk
bestimmt sehr gut.
Ich habe sofort
eine Bindung zu ihm verspürt.
Ich glaube, Soraya ist glücklich.
- Ja.
* Gefühlvoller Soul-Song: "A
Natural Woman" von Aretha Franklin *
# Cause you make me feel,
you make me feel,
# you make me feel
like a natural woman.
Wenig später
erreicht Corona die Schweiz
und bringt das Leben zum Stillstand.
In Spitälern werden nicht lebens-
wichtige Operation aufgeschoben:
Hoffnung weicht der Ungewissheit.
Die Menschen bleiben zu Hause
und haben Zeit, nachzudenken.
Hi, wegen Corona müssen wir
immer noch zu Hause bleiben.
Ich weiss jetzt,
dass ich Soraya bin und nicht Josué.
Und ich bin nicht schuld daran,
dass es Josué nicht gibt,
weil ich von Anfang an hier war.
Weil manchmal
hatte ich ein schlechtes Gewissen
und fragte mich ständig, was Josué
wohl aus seinem Leben gemacht hätte.
Aber ich merke, dass ich
nicht mehr der kleine Josué bin,
sondern ich bin Soraya.
Ziemlich eigenständig,
ich versuche es jedenfalls manchmal.
Und ich werde dann kein Gorilla
oder keine Transgender-Hure sein.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass ich auch etwas wert bin.
Und ich habe auch ein Recht dazu,
um alles zu fordern,
was mir das Leben zu bieten hat.
Und es ist eben so,
dass ich wegen dieses kleinen Teils
irgendwie so alles verpasse,
was ich im Leben noch haben könnte.
Und ja ...
Ich habe ja noch einen Freund.
Und ich habe gemerkt ...
Es tut mir leid,
wenn ich das so sagen muss,
aber ich glaube,
ich muss mich von ihm trennen.
Naomi ist als ältere Schwester
für ein Soraya ein Vorbild.
Bei ihr kann sie sich Rat holen.
Ich weiss nicht, es ist seltsam.
Ich frage mich, ob ich ihn noch
liebe, und was ich überhaupt will,
ob ich überhaupt
eine Beziehung will.
Ich meine, ich bin ...
- Meinst du grundsätzlich?
Ja, ich bin 17
und habe jetzt eigentlich
gar keinen Bock auf eine Beziehung.
Ich habe eher Bock zum ...
Ich weiss nicht, jedenfalls nichts
Festes jetzt gerade, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich verbinde die Operation
eben mit meiner Vorstellung
als ein Tor zur Freiheit.
Weil erst,
wenn ich operiert sein werde,
werde ich frei sein, zu tun und zu
lassen, was und mit wem ich will.
Denkst du nicht, in einer Beziehung
könne man sich auch frei fühlen?
Eher weniger, und wenn,
dann muss es wirklich jemand sein,
es tut mir leid,
der mit mir auch einmal
einen Klub besuchen würde.
Weil ich bin ähnlich wie Mami:
Wir brauchen jemanden
mit einem inneren Feuer, weisst du.
Wenn du die Arme seitlich abstützt,
siehst du so männlich aus.
Oder so?
- Das sieht seltsam aus, finde ich.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Wow, die wurde super, schau!
Nein, bäh!
Voll keine Kurven, ich sehe aus
wie meine alte Lehrerin.
Nimm das andere Bein nach vorne,
das bringt dir mehr S-Kurve.
Ah, ja.
Seit dem Beginn unserer Dreharbeiten
vor vier Jahren wünscht sich Soraya,
auch anatomisch zur Frau zu werden.
Doch erneut
trüben sich die Aussichten
auf eine baldige Operation.
Eliana hat
bei der Krankenkasse beantragt,
dass diese Kosten für den Eingriff in
München übernimmt, rund 20'000 Euro.
Sie schreiben, wir seien mit
der Grundversicherung nicht gedeckt,
ausser es wäre ein Notfall,
dann würden sie
eine Behandlung im Ausland bezahlen.
Sie empfehlen uns, eine Lösung
in der Schweiz zu suchen.
Ich hätte nicht erwartet,
dass sie überhaupt nichts bezahlen,
dass sie gerade alles absagen.
Jetzt sind wir eben
vergebens nach München gefahren.
Ich habe gehofft, die Operation
wäre im Januar oder Februar möglich,
aber anscheinend wird es
doch noch etwas länger dauern.
Es gibt
noch eine schlechte Nachricht,
sie betrifft
die Lehrstelle beim Zahnarzt.
Er hat mir dann geschrieben,
dass es ihm doch nicht gehe,
weil er während
der aktuellen Corona-Lage
keine Lernende aufnehmen könne,
weil sie zu wenig Platz hätten usw.
Ich verstehe das, ist ja logisch,
dass es ihnen während Corona
nicht möglich ist,
aber für mich ist das
jetzt recht doof,
weil ich jetzt
auch wieder im Ungewissen bin.
Es folgen Wochen und Monate,
in denen sich kaum etwas bewegt.
Sie schlagen Soraya aufs Gemüt.
Momentan geht es mir nicht so gut.
Also ...
Es ist einfach ...
Manchmal habe ich keinen Bock mehr,
auf dieser Welt zu sein.
Eigentlich würde ich am liebsten
mein Zimmer nie mehr verlassen.
Nächsten Sonntag will der
Filmemacher mit uns weiterdrehen.
Ehrlich gesagt
habe ich auch darauf keine Lust.
Ich habe eigentlich
auf gar nichts Lust.
Ich habe keine Lust,
meine Freunde zu sehen,
keine Lust, meine Familie zu sehen.
Im Moment wäre ich
einfach gerne mal allein, irgendwie.
Eliana macht sich Sorgen
um ihre Tochter.
Auch sie hat in letzter Zeit
den Draht zu Soraya etwas verloren.
Die beiden streiten sich oft.
Es benötigt Kraft, sie zu begleiten
und für sie da zu sein.
Es gelingt mir auch
nicht immer gleich gut.
Ab und zu muss ich mich abgrenzen,
wenn es mir zu viel wird,
das hat dann aber
mehr mit ihrer Laune zu tun.
Und ...
An manchen Tagen gelingt es mir gut,
an anderen fehlen mir um sie herum
Kraft, Energie und Nerven.
Zweimal startet Soraya
ein Praktikum in einer Kinderkrippe
und bricht es wieder ab.
Es fehlt an einer Perspektive.
Solange sie die gewünschte OP nicht
vornehmen kann, ist sie blockiert.
Ich merke, dass diese OP
bei ihr einfach ein Riesenthema ist.
Und es ist das Einzige,
woran sie denken kann:
"Wann wird es endlich so weit sein?"
Diese Ungewissheit, wann die OP
sein wird, ist ebenfalls ein Teil,
der sie in ein Loch stürzt.
Z.T. mache ich mir schon Sorgen.
Eliana hat den Krankenkassenentscheid
angefochten.
Ein Gutachten soll belegen,
dass Soraya aufgrund ihres Alters
zwingend in München
operiert werden muss.
Wiederum verstreichen Monate.
Und auch als der Winter kommt,
ist der Entscheid der Krankenkasse
noch nicht gefallen.
Es ist Sorayas 18. Geburtstag.
Sie fühlt sich vom Leben betrogen und
manchmal selber wie eine Betrügerin.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Solange ich nicht operiert bin,
bin ich ein Bub in Mädchenkleidern.
Für mich ist es etwas anderes,
in den Spiegel zu schauen,
als für normale Mädchen.
Weil ich noch immer weiss,
wie ich früher ausgesehen habe.
Jahrelang blickte ich in den Spiegel
und sah einen Jungen.
Und das ist
unterdessen schon etwas anders,
wenn ich jetzt
in den Spiegel blicke.
Aber man sieht immer noch ...
Also ich sehe auf alle Fälle das ...
... das Andere an mir.
Ich weiss nicht, das ist auch so
ein Ding, wie es nachher sein wird,
ob ich mich nach der Operation
anders fühlen werde
oder mich noch
genau gleich fühlen werde.
Es ist vorerst
ein Schritt in die Eigenständigkeit,
damit ich anfangen kann, mir selbst
eine Persönlichkeit zu bilden.
Hey Sister ...
Ich habe geheult beim Interview,
voll peinlich.
Aha.
Ich habe Hunger,
aber meine Familie
kommt in einer halben Stunde zurück.
Also, macht euch bereit!
Auf Sorayas Volljährigkeit!
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Der Frühling bringt Veränderung.
Soraya und Eliana
sind erneut umgezogen.
Soraya wollte den Umzug nicht.
Vor ein paar Tagen traf
die Nachricht der Krankenkasse ein.
Auslandbehandlung Kostengutsprache.
Sehr geehrte Frau sowieso,
es gibt Ausnahmefälle,
welche es der obligatorischen
Grundversicherung erlauben,
Kosten im Ausland zu übernehmen.
Für die Behandlung
im Rotkreuzklinikum München
sind die Voraussetzungen erfüllt.
Ich freue mich natürlich sehr, dass
das lange Warten bald ein Ende hat.
Es ist nicht so,
dass es damit abgeschlossen wäre,
aber es bedeutet für Soraya
bestimmt eine Erleichterung,
auch für uns als Familie,
dass es jetzt weitergeht.
dass der nächste Schritt
stattfinden kann.
Wie hat Soraya reagiert?
Anders, als ich gedacht habe:
Sie zeigte nicht viele Emotionen,
nahm den Entscheid zur Kenntnis,
aber ich denke, innerlich
wird sie sich gefreut haben.
Klar, hat es mir viel bedeutet,
ich habe mich schon gefreut.
D.h., dass ich endlich einen Termin
mit Herrn Schöll vereinbaren kann,
nach München fahren ...
... und mein Schnäbi
wegoperieren kann.
Grob gesagt
heisst es das eigentlich.
Mehr heisst es nicht.
Es ist irgendwie, ja, komisch,
dass etwas so Kleines
so viel Zeit und Aufwand benötigt.
Sie findet,
sie habe ihre Jugend verpasst.
Mein Plan war nicht,
mit 18 Jahren noch Jungfrau zu sein.
Es ist auch deshalb seltsam,
weil alle in meinem Freundeskreis
reden alle davon, wie es ist,
was sie tun,
mit wem sie es tun, wo sie es tun.
Und ich bin eben ... ja ...
Weitere sieben Monate verstreichen.
Auch in München
gab's eine Wartefrist.
In wenigen Tagen
ist es endlich so weit.
Ich bin aufgeregt,
weil es nur noch wenige Tage dauert.
Jahrelang habe ich darauf gewartet,
diese Operation machen zu lassen.
Aber ich bin froh,
dass es jetzt endlich geklappt hat,
dass ich mich in fünf Tagen
auf den Weg nach Bayern machen kann.
Auf einen Weg, den zu gehen,
sich Soraya schon so lange ausmalt.
Wann ist man alt genug,
um zu wissen, wer man ist?
Alt genug, seinem Gefühl
zu vertrauen, wenn feststeht:
Hier gibt es keinen Weg zurück.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Kurzfristig ändert
der Operationsplan.
Nicht der Arzt,
den Soraya schon kennengelernt hat,
wird sie operieren.
Mein Name ist Dr. Morath.
Sie sind die Patientin?
Ich wollte mit Ihnen kurz
über die OP morgen sprechen.
Sie sprachen mit meinem Kollegen
schon ausführlich,
aber vielleicht
ergaben sich noch Fragen
oder Sie wollen noch etwas wissen
oder haben etwas nicht verstanden.
Ja, gerne.
Morgen um etwa 7.15 Uhr geht's los,
dann werden Sie zur OP abgeholt.
Sie bekommen vorher
eine kleine Beruhigungstablette.
Jeglicher Schmuck und alles
Metall am Körper kommt bitte weg.
Zur OP selber: Wir entfernen
den Penis, wir entfernen den Hoden.
D.h., Sie werden
unwiederbringlich unfruchtbar.
Ja?
- Ja.- Das muss man wissen.
Es ist extrem wichtig, offen
und ehrlich mit Ihnen zu sprechen,
dass wir alle Risiken ansprechen.
Sie können in letzter Konsequenz
immer noch sagen:
"Ich lasse die OP nicht machen."
Das ist
ein unwiederbringlicher Schritt,
da müssen sie einfach alles wissen.
Und wenn Sie dann trotzdem sagen:
"Ich will die OP",
dann ist es
auch die richtige Entscheidung.
Am Ende der OP
stecken wir in die neue Scheide
einen Schaumstoff-Stent.
Dann wird jeden Tag
auf dem gynäkologischen Stuhl
in die Scheide reingeschaut,
wird die gespült und austamponiert,
bis der Katheter raus kann.
Danach beginnen wir damit,
die Scheide zu bougieren.
Die ersten Tage machen wir das
und danach bringen wir es Ihnen bei.
Sie müssen das
wirklich gut und sicher beherrschen.
Denn wenn Sie nicht von Anfang an
bougieren, schrumpft das wieder zu.
Das haben Sie dann fürs Leben lang.
- Ja, okay.
Hier steht, was wir machen
und was passieren kann.
Wenn wir Sie operieren sollen,
müssten Sie hier unterschreiben.
Soraya ist volljährig,
sie trägt nun alleine die
Verantwortung für ihren Entscheid.
Sie kriegen eine Kopie und dürfen
das alles noch mal in Ruhe lesen.
Ja, das erste Blatt.- Danke schön.
- Und das zweite Blatt.
Gut, dann bis morgen.
- Bis morgen.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Auf Wiedersehen, Frau Morath.
Ich habe schon
etwas Angst vor allem:
Ich habe Angst vor der Spritze,
der Narkose und vor dem Schlauch,
den sie mir in den Rachen stecken.
Ich habe Angst vor dem Bougieren,
davor, dass sie mich aufschlitzen
und alles neu machen.
Ich habe wirklich grosse Angst.
Aber ich freue mich auch.
Ich wäre nicht hier,
wenn ich es nicht wollte.
Ja.
Verabschiede dich
zum letzten Mal von deinem Sohn.
Nein, das habe ich
schon längst getan.
Ich muss weinen.
- Nein, das packen wir, Soraya.
Ich habe Angst.
Danke, dass ihr mich begleitet habt.
Danke fürs Fahren
und deine Unterstützung.
Dein Bart kitzelt.
Ich hab dich lieb.
Tschüss.
- Bis morgen.
Tschau Papi.
- Tschüss.
Mach's gut.
Es kommt alles gut, tschau.
Hab euch lieb.
- Hab dich auch lieb.
Eine letzte Nacht
im biologischen Geschlecht.
Noch vor Tagesanbruch wird Sorayas
Leben in eine neue Richtung gelenkt.
* Schwebende Klänge *
Kann fehlendes Glück operiert werden?
Sechs Jahre lang
hat sie diesen Tag ersehnt.
Soraya hat sich ihr Schicksal
nicht ausgesucht.
Für sie scheint die Operation
keine Wahl,
sondern eine Notwendigkeit zu sein.
Die Notwendigkeit,
ihr körperliches Geschlecht
dem gefühlten Geschlecht als Frau
anzupassen.
Nach dreieinhalb Stunden
ist der Eingriff zu Ende.
* Schwebende Gitarrenklänge *
Aua.
- Was tut dir weh?
Meine neue Muschi, was denn sonst?
Es fühlt sich jetzt schon toll an.
Ja?
- Toll.- Toll.
Wie merkst du das?
Wie fühlt es sich an?
Es ist nichts mehr da.
Hast du daran herumgetastet?
- Nein.
Ich fasse das in den
nächsten drei Wochen nicht an.
Du fühlst,
dass es nicht mehr da ist?
Ja.
Und ich fühle, dass Watteteile
und dieser Ring drin sind.
Hallo, ich wollte noch mal nach
Ihnen schauen. Wie geht's Ihnen?
Ein bisschen müde?
- Ja, und es blutet.
Es blutet, das darf es.
Bei der OP ist alles gut gegangen,
es gab keine Komplikationen.
Wir waren auch gut in der Zeit,
brauchten ungefähr 3 Std.
Dass es jetzt
ein bisschen nachblutet,
ist im Rahmen der OP ganz normal.
Schauen wir mal drunter,
ganz vorsichtig, es passiert nichts.
Ist nicht schlimm.
Das nehmen wir weg,
legen Frisches nach.
Das ersetzen wir
durch frische Wäsche, genau.
Denken Sie,
dass alles gut gegangen ist?
Es ist alles gut gegangen, ja.
Hübsche, kleine Schamlippen,
die Scheide ist okay geworden,
auch wenn wir
nicht luxus viel Haut hatten,
aber wir haben aus dem,
was wir hatten, das Beste gemacht.
Die Klitoris ist rosa, die lebt,
das passt alles. Okay?
Danke vielmals.
- Sehr gerne.
Versuchen Sie, etwas zu schlafen,
morgen schaut die Welt
schon wieder besser aus.
Gute Nacht, alles Gute,
auf Wiedersehen.
Vielen Dank, Frau Morath.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Die Eltern werden ihre Tochter
schon übermorgen zurücklassen müssen.
Geplant ist, dass Soraya zwei bis
drei Wochen im Spital bleiben wird.
Ich bin heute zweimal aufgestanden
und sogar etwas rumgelaufen.
Es hat sich angefühlt,
wie erste Schritte in meinem Leben.
Ich bin schon jetzt seit zwei,
nein, drei Wochen im Spital.
Ich habe einen Handschuh erhalten.
Nachher sagten sie, ich müsse mich
damit selbst erforschen.
Dann fingerte ich damit herum.
Dann fuhr ich
mit einigen Fingern hinein.
Und es fühlte sich
irgendwie so toll an.
Ich habe voll die Freude.
Drei Wochen nach der OP
ist Soraya immer noch im Spital.
Geh ran, Soraya!
Es gab einen Infekt
und Schwierigkeiten beim Bougieren.
Hey Paps.
- Hallo Soraya.
Ist das definitiv, dass du noch
eine Woche länger bleiben musst?
Ja.
- Wirklich?
Also wirklich erst
übernächstes Wochenende?
Erst dann?
- Ja.
Oje.
Ach.
Bougieren hat noch nicht geklappt?
Nein, deswegen wollen sie mich noch
eine Woche länger hierbehalten.
Dann wärst du insgesamt
vier Wochen dort gewesen.
Ja.- Mhm, das ist eine lange Zeit.
- So blöd!
Tschau.
Wir hören uns wieder,
tschau, tschau.
Eine Woche später
bringt Titus sie nach Hause.
Wegen Corona waren die Spitalbesuche
stark eingeschränkt.
Die Mutter durfte Soraya
vier Wochen lang nicht besuchen.
Willkommen zu Hause.
Willst du schon schlafen gehen?
Endlich mein eigenes Bett,
ich habe es vermisst.
Ich freue mich so,
wieder zu Hause zu sein.
Aber ich habe auch Angst, weil
ich jetzt alles selbst machen muss
und nicht einfach klingeln kann,
damit eine Pflegerin kommt
und mir hilft.
Jetzt rufst du: "Mama".
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
"Mama!" - das habe ich vermisst.
Und du hast das Knutschen
mit Mami vermisst?
Ja, ich habe dich generell vermisst.
Ich könnte
weinen und lachen gleichzeitig.
Es tut weh,
aber irgendwie ist es auch ...
Ich bin froh,
dass es endlich getan ist.
Jetzt muss ich das Bougieren
noch fünf Monate durchziehen,
dann kann ich ...
Ich fühle mich lebendig,
ich fühle mich wirklich ich.
Ich kann es nicht beschreiben.
Fünf Monate später -
in Zürich findet die Pride statt
unter dem Motto: trans -
Soraya mittendrin.
Nach sechs Jahren ist sie am Ziel.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden
nach der Operation.
Ich kann endlich Bikinis anziehen.
Ich fühle mich auch wohler
unter anderen Menschen.
Ich merke, dass ich seit der OP
mehr im Reinen mit mir selbst bin.
* Technomusik *
Ich sehe vor mir
das Bild einer Raupe,
die sich im Kokon
geschützt und beschützt fühlt -
auch mit mir als Mutter
und die Familie um sie.
Seit der Operation merke ich,
wie sie aus diesem Kokon ausbricht.
Sie will jetzt
wirklich die Welt erforschen.
Sie will jetzt wirklich losfliegen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
etwas hat sie befreit.
Weil ich mich als Mädchen fühlte,
trug ich lange Zeit
einen Groll oder Wut mit mir herum,
die sich
gegen alles und jeden richtete.
Jetzt, nach der Operation,
ist das Meiste davon weg.
Ich fühle mich
nicht wie ein neuer Mensch,
aber ich fühle mich besser
in meinem Körper,
und auch mehr in der Welt und
mehr angekommen in der Gesellschaft.
Am Anfang war ich skeptisch.
Ich wollte irgendwie
auch nicht wahrhaben,
dass das so ist.
Dass sie das tun musste,
ist für mich jetzt
eigentlich völlig klar.
Ich denke,
wenn ich ein Junge gewesen wäre,
wäre das Leben
um einiges einfacher gewesen.
Aber ich hatte keine echte Wahl.
Damals hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass der Weg derart
lange und beschwerlich sein würde,
dass mein Leben dadurch
so stark beeinflusst würde.
Ich wünsche mir einfach,
dass sie glücklich ist,
das ist für mich das Wichtigste.
Der Abschluss
ist zugleich ein Anfang.
Jetzt geht es darum,
im neuen Leben Fuss zu fassen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Roger Schmid - 2022